ils ont battu le pavé dans les rues de
basse terre avec un seul mot d'ordre on
finir avec le racisme et les violences
policières
mardi soir une centaine de guadeloupéens
se sont donné rendez vous pour une
marche aux flambeaux en hommage à
georges floyd à l'arrivée des concerts
et des prises de parole notamment celles
des organisations à l'origine de la
mobilisation comme le comité
international des peuples noirs bas nous
en tant que afro caribéens
nous sommes absolument toucher je
voulais un peu aux nourrissons son image
ou ne reste à présent en venant ici ce
soir ça se passe tous les jours en
france des jeunes meurent ils ne sont
pas armés sont tués par la police dans
un monde de carnivores et les herbivores
seront toujours des proies
on est au 21ème siècle et ce n'est pas
possible que des personnes sur phase
arrêtée de façon
et justifier cette personne se fassent
tuer qu'on soit blanc qu'on soit noir
qu'on soit jaune peu importe nous sommes
des humains et tout humain a droit au
respect il est devenu non pas le héros
des hommes noirs ça n'est pas vrai il
est devenu le héros de l'humanité parce
qu'il oblige l'humanité à se regarder en
face
en guadeloupe comme à paris à bristol ou
à washington
les manifestants s'insurge contre les
symboles encore visibles du colonialisme
et de l'esclavagé statut des noms de
rues comme les emblèmes insultant d'un
passé douloureux à basse terre c'est la
rue jules ferry qui fait débat
un tac historienne je sais très bien ce
que je ferry a dit concernant les
civilisations supérieurs qui ont le
droit de venir donner la leçon devenir
convertir à la civilisation les peuples
inférieurs ça c'est scandaleux et
renault mines rue je ne pense pas que ça
fera avancer les choses je pouvoir ça
juste comme un devoir de mémoire
quelque chose d'important c'est sûr mais
je ne pense pas que ça fera avancer les
choses et je pense qu'il faut renommer
non seulement la wii jules ferry mais
fera nommer toutes les roues et de la
guadeloupe et des antilles parce que ce
sont des rues en général d'anciens
esclavagiste et donc il n'était pas
autant pour nous c nous voulons nous
reconstruire si nous voulons faire en
sorte que la vérité historique soit
faite a dit il faut absolument revoir
tout c'est toutes ces rues
ce soir là les pas des marcheurs ont
mené la foule plus loin que jusqu'au
simple hommage
une marche qui dépasse georges floyd sur
une île française toujours marqué par
l'esclavagé et la domination coloniale